morning all boris johnson is joining the
diplomatic efforts to prevent a war in
ukraine dining street says he will speak
to president putin next week and visit
the region in the coming days
uh president bandan meanwhile has
announced he'll be moving u.s troops to
eastern europe and nato countries in the
near term as the military buildup around
ukraine continues but in kiev itself the
ukrainian president has warned that all
the talk of a possible russian invasion
is just creating panic well tensions
between russia and ukraine have
certainly been ratcheting up and are now
expanding beyond the borders of the two
countries
forces in eastern europe now comprise
key members of nato including the united
states there's a nato military presence
in poland germany lithuania latvia
romania and bulgaria
but this is what faces europe 100 000
russian troops on the entire length of
the european border and into its ally
belarus while in lithuania fighter jets
from denmark poland and belgium will be
flying above the baltic states to police
the airspace our international affairs
editor dominic wagon reports now from
the ukrainian capital
in the snowy wastes of western ukraine
british supplied anti-tank missiles
being put through their paces
if russia does launch an invasion of
tanks they can expect this kind of
reception
but how soon that invasion could happen
is reportedly now causing a rift between
the u.s and ukraine
while america says an imminent
invasion's a real possibility ukraine's
president vladimir zelinsky is insisting
it isn't
there are those who suspect that you are
talking down the threat of an imminent
invasion just to preserve your economy
and actually the americans are right it
is a real possibility that that could
happen imminently
is that what's really going on here
we do understand what's happening and
we're talking about this we're talking
about this with our people but we have
been in this situation for eight years
so we shouldn't be only looking up we're
also looking on the ground and for us
it's an important question
we may lose the current economy of our
country people come first
in an hour of questions the president
was asked again and again about
differences with america
president zielinski has been walking a
fine line between his government's
position and america's assessment of the
threat russia currently poses his
officials though have been more blunt
one ukrainian security official said
today allies should supply weapons but
otherwise keep quiet
it's all welcome news to vladimir putin
as the russian leader keeps the world
guessing about his intentions his
foreign minister was sounding diplomatic
our president already said that if our
attempts to negotiate over suitable
security guarantees in europe does not
give any result then we will respond
answering that direct question about
what kind of response it could be he
said any kind my decision will be based
on our military leaders proposals
but america's ambassador to moscow
wasn't convinced
it's the equivalent of if you and i were
were having a discussion or negotiation
if i put a gun on the table and say that
i come in peace
uh you know that's uh that's that's
threatening
the daily feed of russian propaganda
goes on while talking diplomacy it seems
russia is still preparing its military
for conflict
dominic waghorn sky news kiev
meanwhile the u.s president joe biden
reiterated overnight that he will be
moving u.s troops to eastern europe in
response to russian forces massing on
the ukrainian border he spoke to
reporters at joint base entrance in
maryland
any update on the situation in ukraine
no not in the last couple hours have you
decided how soon you would be moving us
troops to eastern europe
i'll be moving the u.s church eastern
europe and the nato countries in the
near term
a few of the days other stories now and
the home secretary pretty patel has
approved the extradition of the british
tech magnate mike lynch to the united
states to face criminal charges after he
lost a fraud case in london yesterday
in what's believed to be the biggest
civil fraud trial in british history dr
lynch was accused of deliberately
overstating the value of his software
company when he sold it to hewlett
packard in a multi-billion dollar deal
11 years ago
jordy mitchell has become just the
latest high-profile name to wade into
the row over spotify platforming
anti-vaccine content
the singer has joined neil young in
asking for her music to be removed from
the platform over concerns that the
streaming giant promotes joe rogan's
podcast who she says has been spreading
lies about covet
now there are fears for the safety of an
entire community in afghanistan who say
they are being persecuted and hunted
down by the taliban
the minority hazara people are now
living in fear every day of the ruling
regime the u.n secretary general antonio
gutierrez has warned that without more
help afghanistan is hanging by a thread
our special correspondent alex crawford
has been to meet a community that has
now gone into hiding
they're all on the run
going from house to house to try to keep
ahead of taliban fighters bent on
revenge
all of them worked for or were trained
by the foreigners who pulled out nearly
six months ago
many have letters of commendation and
pictures alongside their former foreign
friends
now they and their children are taliban
targets feeling abandoned by former
allies and hunted by those now in power
they left us behind and now we're not
safe so i ask the international
community to please help us either with
our security here or get us out of here
in this place she was shot yes while she
was traveling her mother was a soldier
in the afghan army gunned down a few
months ago the rest of the family are
terrified they're next
we are nervous about for our security
our family
we don't want to go another country or
any
good situation we want to
live in safe situation in our country
but this is not possible this is our
video the taliban search my home
they say the taliban promises of an
amnesty for those who worked with the
foreigners have come to nothing
unbelievable
and they say wrong they say alive
and how among the group is the son of
the female head of heratz women's prison
his mother aliyah as easy disappeared
nearly four months ago and they've not
seen her since
[Music]
he breaks down telling us they think
she's being held by the taliban because
she's a woman and from the hazara ethnic
group
the meeting quickly splits up they're
all hazaras
and very anxious words will get out that
they hear
they head back into hiding
since the taliban took power thousands
of hazaras have fled
half of those who lived here have gone
mostly over the border to iran
one of the elders tells us the
persecution they felt for so long is far
worse under the taliban
we're all from the same country but they
don't recognize the hazaras as their
fellow countrymen when we go to
government offices they won't even talk
to us
the challenge is making sure the aid
reaches those who need it and there are
concerns it's being misused by the
taliban
with most money frozen and aid halted by
the international community the new
taliban regime has been offering food
aid to workers in exchange for salaries
but that's led to claims that the aid's
only going to taliban supporters
that's hit the hazara worst they've
always been anti-taliban and whilst the
un's trying to ensure aid goes through
groups they've approved
most hazara we spoke to feel
it's happening all over afghanistan she
says but the hazara of the poorest and
worst hit and the taliban don't like us
for the hazara the war is not over
this was the latest bombing less than a
week ago in the heart of the hazard
community
seven people were killed mostly women
isk said they did it for the hazaras the
attacks are coming from all sides
among the victims was a single mother
her five young children are now all
alone
they're terrified and helpless
there was no one to help my mother she
tells us
and if anyone had helped she'd still be
alive
she's also angry at the lack of
everything here
there wasn't even an ambulance she goes
on they took them to hospital in private
cars
they're still in shock but they know
this means trying to find work in a land
that doesn't even recognize their right
to do that
my little sister cries all night until
morning she says asking where her mother
is she's very young and scared
female hazara and now orphans with no
one to look after them
alex crawford sky news in her act
now after days and weeks of waiting sky
news understands that sue graves reports
on those downing street parties will
land on the prime minister's desk in the
coming hours or days
but there's certainly much uncertainty
about how much will be released to the
public after the metropolitan police
requested that a redacted version be
published to ensure that nothing
jeopardizes their own inquiry now speak
to our political correspondent rob
powell who's in westminster for us this
morning um rob so in the coming hours or
days the report will be received well it
looks like it's gonna be a busy few days
for the prime minister then yeah shortly
the report will go to the pm and then
after that
we know that boris johnson plans to
make what he has given public give it to
mps as well and then make a statement to
the house of commons
as well
the fact that sue gray has decided that
she wants to put the report out before
the metropolitan police finish their
investigation means though that
the detail in that report about the
events that the police are investigating
will be
minimized that not all of the
information that would have initially
gone in there
will uh be present i think on a surface
level it's generally accepted here in
westminster that's probably good news
for boris johnson because it decreases
the chance of a sort of acute moment of
danger where a big unvarnished report
threatens to sort of tip mps over the
edge
and put their letters of no confidence
in to try and remove
the prime minister that said there's a
lot of unknowns we don't know how bad
the grey report will be for the prime
minister even in a redacted form there
will be a lot of pressure here in
westminster for the full details to come
out if there's a feeling that anything
uh too damaging
is being held back of course there's
also the chance as well of additional
damaging details being leaked or made
public um in other ways i think boris
johnson is also helped politically in
terms of
his fight to stay in his position by the
fact that there is a lot of other stuff
going on at the moment we learn
overnight that he will uh
phone court may have a phone call with
president putin about the situation in
ukraine in the coming days he will also
make a trip
to the region
next week presenting the possibility
that mps may be discussing his future
while he is in ukraine talking about
a potential russian invasion
also this weekend boris johnson will be
considering various options he's been
presented with in terms of bolstering
troop deployments in the region as well
so it's clear that he's not just
interested in talking the foreign
secretary liz trust as well who's
expected in moscow in the coming couple
of weeks will be in the commons on
monday announcing a beefed up sanctions
regime against russia as well so the
situation in ukraine cost of living
rising energy bills the potential for
the leveling up white paper that big
plank of government policy coming next
week i think the fact that there is so
much other stuff happening big important
stuff as well potentially does help
boris johnson when he appeals to mps to
essentially give him some more time and
not to move against him
rob thank you
uh well let's return uh to the prime
minister and his trip to the region uh
welcome trip to ukraine we should point
out i will join by the conservative mp
to buy sell and of course chair of the
commons defense select committee mr
elwood great to see you this morning um
one hope in your mind that boris
johnson's arrival on the scene can
actually sort this situation out with
russia i'm being slightly facetious but
of course it is an important trip that
he's making
it is an important trip but we need to
keep this in perspective um after
afghanistan you know the west has looked
somewhat disunited from a russian
perspective there's never been a better
time to invade ukraine something putin
has been wanting to do for a long time
he's enjoying this international
attention every time a leader puts their
hand up and says i'm going to go to
moscow to try and talk this of course
he's going to say yes he is spinning
this out i doubt whether any invasion
will take place until after the beijing
olympics china would have made sure of
that but more widely i'm pleased to see
that we're beginning to appreciate why
ukraine is important and invasion would
have huge consequences for oil and gas
prices not just in ukraine right across
europe there's there's also the issue of
grain one third of the world's grain
comes from ukraine our food prices would
also go up indeed some of the food
perhaps on our shelves might even
disappear so the penny is dropping and
i'm encouraging that we need a
simpler but more effective solution and
that's directly directly supporting
ukraine it's time to show strength a
sense of purpose not to hesitate and not
to hide behind the fact that ukraine is
not a nato member and i hope britain has
you know gains greater resolve to
recognize the importance of supporting
our democratic ally and make putin's
think twice this is our cuban missile
crisis moment and we must not blink
what then mr railwood should be the
extent or perhaps the limits on british
involvement in whatever does transpire
on the ukrainian border well absolutely
we can't do things alone
putin is exploiting the collective
weakness across europe and beyond if you
think about it you know what's going on
in washington berlin paris and indeed
london we've all been facing different
directions if we are going to have
greater resolve here we must all look in
the same direction but that's where the
convening power comes in that's where
britain can step forward america is
hesitating here a little bit if we offer
that convening power put forward a plan
to support ukraine in its time of need
i'm sure other nations will then follow
is there an inevitability to conflict
between the west and russia over at the
issue of ukraine absolutely we played
into putin's hands for the last number
of months he knows that if sanctions are
put in place firstly they will have
little effect and secondly he's very
content he's made the rather grander
strategic decision to turn to the east
to look to china any sanctions that are
put in place he will actually end up
being able to take his own country
convince his own people look the west
don't want us they're our enemy let's
look to the east in my personal view you
know there needs to be an off-ramp over
the next couple of decades that allows
russia to turn back to look to the west
where it's more comfortable that won't
happen under putin but what happens in
the next few months to do with ukraine
has such bigger consequences this is a a
turning point in our history and we need
to recognize this bigger picture
but but it's surely in the shorter term
uh mr elwood as regards vladimir putin
we're looking for an exit ramp for him
right now aren't we in the sense that he
will be unwilling uh perhaps unable even
to remove those hundred thousand troops
from the ukrainian border without some
sort of concession that he can take back
to uh to his electorate in the west
russia well i don't believe he's
answering to his electorate at all i'm
not sure the the russian people want
this he's uh spinning out the idea that
nato is the aggressor that wants to
actually attack uh ukraine that is not
true at all ukraine is wanting to you
know go down the democratic path and
they are being attacked it is absolutely
right for us to defend ukraine in its
moment of need we need to understand the
language that the putin respects and
that's the use of force if we actually
put in a nato division in there with uh
enhanced force capabilities in the
surrounding nations he will think twice
he will not want to trigger another
european war on the scale that's the
language putin understands that's the
direction that we should be going
given their veto do you think the russia
will respect anything that the united
nations says on this issue well you
actually point to one of the problems
that we have at the moment which is why
there's a 1930s feel to the world at the
moment these international institutions
aren't able to hold
nations to account it requires good
nations as was saw in the last century
to step forward to be bold and not be
intimidated by the likes of putin and
other authoritarian regimes
mr ellwood you will understand that we
cannot have a member of parliament on
the program at the moment and not
reference the the the sue grey report
what is your view of what has happened
over the past 24 hours with with the
metropolitan police perhaps muddying the
waters slightly and forcing redactions
into the report
yeah i mean it's it's been a horrible
few weeks you know problems with the the
rules written by number 10
not followed by number 10
and latterly to add to that uh misery
it's now the handling of the crisis
which is also a concern and we must not
forget this is all actually happening
under the
the gaze of the nation and they're
looking for evidence that we are going
to change that we want to rebuild trust
that we're sort of fit to govern so this
discussion this talk this suggestion
that somehow the sue gray report um
which we've waited for so long might
even be redacted or somehow watered down
i don't will not go down well with with
colleagues there remains a deluge of
fury with the british public appalled by
what's happened and they want to see
that we're on the road to change the
command the discipline the cultural
changes will actually be introduced to
number 10 not any form of cover-up not
any form of simply trying to get the
prime minister to short-term survival
but genuine reform that can actually
take our country forward
to myself great to see you this morning
thanks so much for joining us thank you
a major revamp of the highway code comes
into force today giving cyclists and
pedestrians more rights and more
protection from traffic but it's been
criticized by the aaa which says that
pedestrians could be in more danger from
people not knowing the new rules this
guy's sadia trout joins us now from
richmond park of course one of london's
at top cycling hubs and how are these
new rules going down there
well the whole point of these new rules
is to try and make uh the uk's roads
safer we've already got some of the
safest roads in the world but now what's
happening is nine sections of the
highway code have been updated and about
50 new rules or rules have been either
added or amended now
not all of them
are going to be things that people are
familiar with and i have to say at this
stage that the four the rules do come
into force today
and they're advisories so uh you won't
get fined for non-compliance some of uh
some of it will seem quite new there's
something called a dutch reach which you
might have heard about in the last few
days that's where drivers are being
urged to use their left arm to reach
over and open their car doors and that
that the idea of that is it's meant to
force you to sort of turn your body in
your head and look behind you to to
check if any cyclists are coming i'll go
through some of the changes with you now
now um the new guidelines uh states that
traffic should give way to pedestrians
uh and and when pedestrians are looking
to cross at junctions uh it says
cyclists should ride in the center of
lanes on quieter roads in moving traffic
and when approaching junctions that's to
make themselves as visible as possible
and it's introducing a hierarchy of road
users so drivers will have more
responsibility to those on bikes horses
or on foot and cyclists will have to be
more aware of pedestrians and as i say
these are
advisories only but there are some
concerns about how drivers will respond
to these changes the head of the aaa is
worried that some people will be really
rigid about it and you know stop as soon
as they see a pedestrian at a junction
trying to cross and perhaps be hit
in the back by another vehicle and the
rac is raising concerns about uh that
not many people are aware of these
changes and if that's the case then
someone might know uh that the changes
come into effect somebody else might not
they might end up getting into a clash
on the road over that and a recent
survey found that 33 percent of road
users aren't aware of the changes
including four percent who say they
don't intend to look them up but with us
this morning to review the papers the
broadcaster and author gemma forte and
tom slater editor of spiked online good
to see you again guys um gemma t first
inside the mail um simon jenkins uh
piece today forget party gate how could
we do that well he's suggesting that at
the 4.3 billion loss to fraud might be a
bigger story
and i think he's got a very very good
point just at a point when we're all um
looking at this cost of living crisis
and the extra money that we're all going
to be forking out whilst i think we will
appreciate that the treasury had to just
open up the coffers and furlough as a
success and everything this is an an
egregious waste of money what's
interesting about this is lord agnews is
like an archetypal tory if you like he
he donated to the party he got given a
peerage and a knighthood he campaigned
for vote leave et cetera
and he himself his company has benefited
from government contracts but in
integrity shocker
he has been banging his head up against
the wall and he resigned in parliament
last week having absolutely hit a wall
of complete and utter frustration
because the treasury just seemed to not
care about this money that has been
swindled from the banks so
you expect when you know something's
being rolled out as quickly during a
pandemic you understand there's going to
be some glitches there's going to be
some errors but the government promised
the banks that they would underwrite um
any losses 100
so this kind of gave carte blanche to
the banks just to dole out all this
money in this uh bounce-back loan um
um
thing and basically what's happened is
you've got fraudsters gangsters um
companies that didn't really exist
getting all of this money and the
government just don't seem to care
they're just writing it off and so lord
agnew just furious about this quite
quite rightly and he says this has to be
challenged so since he resigned he did
um get lots of publicity as a result of
that rishi soon that kind of tweeted oh
yes we'll we'll look into it but as lord
agnew has gone on to say
how what are you doing and how can the
banks get away with this after the 2008
financial crash it seems absolutely
unbelievable that they can't be held to
account for this
fraud and yes given that the taxpayer is
going to be paying so much more money
out of their pockets i think it's
extraordinary wasted money yeah indeed
i'm tom just a word from you though on
that on this story as well i mean
dominic cummings is actually quoted in
the article uh in the comment piece uh
describing that
that mad house that exists in whitehall
and the way in which the
interconnectivity just isn't there
between various government departments i
mean what is your view on this story
almost four and a half billion pounds
lost i mean that's a huge amount of
money
it's a huge amount of money and you know
so much of this i think you can put down
to just the unprecedented situation that
the government found themselves in you
know they needed to move at speed the
fundamental thing was how do we prop up
businesses how do we make sure that
people can get through this there's also
been an awful lot of scrutiny of course
about ppe contracts going to people
who've never made ppe in their life all
of these kinds of things which are
genuinely unjust really should be
tackled i guess the issue is when you're
in an unprecedented situation as we were
and the need to act with that level of
efficiency and speed and all the rest of
it you do see cases like this but i
think a big problem and dominic cummings
has often pointed to this quite rightly
in my view
it's the fact that just whitehall
doesn't work very well in normal times
let alone in times of crisis so when it
comes to trying to design schemes like
this when it comes to trying to bring in
the private sector to a particular goal
uh again the processes aren't
necessarily there even without the
spectrum of a global pandemic having to
be brought out so definitely something
which i'm sure needs to be looked into
if we ever find ourselves in anything
resembling a crisis like this again yeah
oh dear goodness hope not um tom though
uh your story though your first story is
the double first in double standards
according to the mail
yes this is an investigation into a
really fascinating case at jesus college
cambridge
so it's chapel has various different
amazing artifacts in it there's a
william morris stained glass window
various kind of priceless sculptures but
there's also a small marble plaque
depicting a guy called tobias roster he
was a sort of 17th century courtier to
charles ii who donated to the college um
but again amidst all of the kind of um
discussions around decolonizing um
universities around links to the slave
trade and trying to reckon with that
this particular plaque has come under
scrutiny because a small amount of his
fortune was gained from the
transatlantic slave trade the the thrust
of this particular investigation though
is asking questions about potential
double standards given the fact that
jesus college has quite close links to
china it's taking about 200 000 pounds
from the chinese state
155 000 pounds from huawei which is of
course the kind of state aligned
telecoms company from china you've got
professors who run uh non-profits which
are essentially paid for by sort of
chinese oligarchs if you like and this
raises a difficult question which is
there's been a lot of kind of again sort
of moral preening i think it's
you could say about some of these kind
of
relics if you like of our ugly past and
the history of colonialism and the slave
trade but at the same time there seems
to be a lack of interest in in issues
like this in the present and if you're
going to pose as being very morally
pious about these issues
then questions are going to be raised
about where you're getting your money
from in the present because when you go
into people with deep pockets often some
of that money won't necessarily come
from the most uh morally unimpeachable
sources and this story in particular
just contrasting that concern about one
benefactor centuries ago who made a
small proportion of his money from the
slave trade with again taking money from
the ccp and what's going on in xinjiang
with the weaker muslims at the moment so
yeah raising difficult questions for the
college there
gemma tell us about the the stealth tax
on graduates that the mail has
discovered
i know well interesting off the back of
the story i was talking about previously
where this 4.3 billion is just sort of
being left
um ministers are being accused of making
the cost of living crisis worse by
freezing the student loan repayment
threshold so this is hitting graduates
really with the tax rise by stealth so
they keep the salary threshold at 27 295
despite inflation rocketing to 5.4 which
is its highest in 30 years so a graduate
who earns 30 000 pounds will end up
paying 113
more towards their student loan than
over the next year that's more than was
previously indicated so it's sort of
like a
almost like going against the contract
that they went into but also let's put
this in context i mean i have a 17 year
old so she went through her gcses during
this time that was bad enough but i kept
thinking i am so glad that she's not at
university stage these are students who
will have sat in a room their university
is
horrendous absolutely awful not the
university experience that you wish to
pay for at all lectures on zoom just
utterly rubbish these are graduates will
be getting their first job and let's
face it no hope of getting on the the
housing ladder as well compared to when
i was young so it you know it really is
quite hard for young people and anybody
who doesn't think so is sort of not very
empathetic so i i think this is a bit
tone deaf
especially given we're seeing you know
as i say 4.3 billion just being written
off by the treasury i just think this is
going to stick in the throat a little
bit i think it might i think it might um
tom take us inside the times to to your
almost namesake tom tuggentac guess what
he fancies being prime minister who'd
have thunk it
who'da thunk it and he's also one of the
first really to come out and make it
explicit although i think it's been
pretty clear that there are various
other candidates but he's he's given
this interview to times radio written up
here where uh tom tugnet is an mp um
he's the chair of the foreign affairs
select committee um and he's essentially
come out with his with his ambitions he
says he's not canvassing support that
there isn't a vacancy yet but that of
course it would be an honor to serve in
that in that position and so on and so
forth
people may be familiar with this sort of
pedigree he was an army officer he
served in iraq in afghanistan very
hawkish on many foreign policy matters
if he was to become pm i'd be slightly
worried we'd be at war with about three
different people by tea time but
nevertheless seen as a kind of move on
from johnson he's trying to position
himself as a character as a character of
integrity and really kind of now um
you're starting to see the field sort of
shape up with rishi sunak and liz trust
obviously seen as the front runners
although they haven't necessarily come
out and declared their intentions yet
and also jeremy hunt the former health
secretary again potentially pondering
another run so yes
even though there's still not a lot of
clarity as to when johnson will go
you're already starting to see the uh
potential successes circling if you like
you certainly can um gemma
in 20 seconds if you can tell us about
the man in his 80s who's been caught out
by the cops
yeah he's been driving without a license
since he was 12 they were absolutely
stunned when they pulled him over
thankfully he hasn't hit anybody in that
time or had any kind of accident but yet
there he is he's been poodling around in
his mini and it's finally caught up with
him